okay so while i'm putting it on live
could
others know tell me about their
background as well pradeep says
he is from uh perrier university
india tamil nadu good to have you here
okay so we would be live on youtube and
if anyone misses out on anything
they can just join on youtube as well
i'll be sharing the link with you all
hi pradeep
if any one of you has any question in
the middle of the session you can
then and they'll put it in the chat box
and our team would be there to
answer your question
i hope everyone has joined and now let's
begin with the webinar
white others can join in the midst of it
as well
so a very warm welcome everyone thank
you for joining today's session
and i would like to welcome you all for
this today's webinar on the overview of
omixlogic genomics in the virtual lab
today we would start with the
introduction to the omixlogic training
and
platforms and then we would hear from
our experts about genomics
and future medicine
followed by a video presentation by our
program mentor dr sona vasudevan
and then we will go through the schedule
of the entire program and go through the
upcoming opportunities
as well so before we start with the talk
i would
want to introduce us we are a u.s
based bioinformatics company who is
working with multiple academic and
commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to make
bioinformatics more accessible omics
logic is an international program that
is running in five different regions
with over 10
000 users around the world and due to
this fast growth our team is working
with
local and regional coordinators that are
helping refine local program logistics
and leverage our online training
resources adapting them to the needs of
the students and researchers around the
world
omixlogic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech
and numerous academic institutions that
have participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
my name is sunalika ray and i'm the
omixlogic community manager responsible
for daily interaction with thousands of
users
that are a part of a bioinformatics
community
managed by pine biotech now coming back
to the program
genomics in the virtual lab is a special
opportunity to learn
about genomics and big data analysis
from world-renowned scientists and a
team of bioinformaticians
working on cutting-edge big data
challenges in biomedical
research in this online program
participants will learn about the
analysis of
high throughput genomics data and would
apply
complex and computationally intensive
data processing steps
to large-scale public domain data
now let me introduce our program mentors
and guest speaker
we have dr harpreet with us she has an
expertise in the
application of statistical machine
learning techniques on biomedical data
and the development of prediction tools
and databases
and she looks after the curriculum
development bioinformatics and data
science course development then we have
dr mohit mazumdar
he is an experienced bioinformatician
with multiple publications
in peer review journals and
collaborations in industry and academia
and over the past several years he has
been developing collaborations with
with universities as a mentor and
project lead for omix logic training and
research fellowship
elia brodsky is the ceo of pine biotech
and then we have our program mentor she
is dr sona vasudevan
professor of biochemistry and molecular
biology
at georgetown university medical college
she would be mentoring our students and
would present disease associated
projects that our
participants can learn from and
ultimately see how genomics is used at
the intersection of data science
and biomedicine dr arigi research
associate professor
center of bioinformatics and
computational biology
department of computer information
sciences university of delaware
would be our guest speaker for the
program dr
araghi leaves the uniprod database
efforts and leads the biocreative
and biocuration efforts as well
now i would like to pass it on to elia
who will be
the co-mentor of the program over to you
ilya
thank you very much i'm going to share
my screen
okay so welcome everyone to this webinar
it's exciting to see all of you here
today
and what i will try to do in my part of
the presentation is to briefly tell you
about
the reason why this program is the right
place for you to start as you're
learning about genomics
so first of all let me briefly introduce
myself
i have been working with pine biotech
for several years now and
i have been a part of many different
presentations and training sessions that
were related to bioinformatics
for a variety of different levels
starting from
faculty and graduate students but also
including high school students so
we have built a team of academic
advisors and collaborators
as well as facilitators that will
include
many different types of people that can
help you along the way
and what we have really been focused on
is how
we can use our expertise and the network
that we
have to bring to you the best possible
experience
learning about bioinformatics in a
virtual setting so how do we take
what we have successfully done offline
and bring it online in a way that all of
you could participate and get an equally
excellent experience learning about
applications of big data to a variety of
biomedical challenges
but also how to work on translational
research challenges that
are relevant to where you are right now
so let me start by kind of telling you
why bioinformatics and genomics is such
a relevant topic today
so from the 1950s after the dna double
helix structure was discovered
right away there was a focus on trying
to understand
what is encoded in the dna and so as a
result of the human genome project
and that led to many other species being
sequenced
we started to really accumulate a huge
volume of data
and that volume of data today is
accessible to anyone
that has access to the internet now
what's interesting about this
is that this data actually comes with
a lot of variation and so the topic of
genomics the study of genomics is really
focused
on looking at the dna code trying to
find
patterns and bugs in the code
that might lead to phenotypic changes or
changes in the actual functional
molecules that our cells use to operate
and function as we grow and so these
bugs in the code could result in
major changes that are associated with
a few different important biomedical
challenges and these include
drug metabolism so for example
the function of different enzymes that
process the drugs that are prescribed to
patients
and that could result in patients being
non-responsive to treatment
or maybe even having a toxic
reaction to a treatment that has to do
with cancer so a lot of cancers are
associated with what's called somatic
mutations mutations that
accumulate as the cells divide and as
they accumulate
that might disrupt some of the
regulatory networks that control
different properties of cells and make
them into what they are causing tumors
to grow
and causing them to spread or
metastasize
that has to do with inherited diseases
and those inherited diseases could be a
result
of many different environmental factors
over a long period of time
as well as rare genetic diseases and so
those rare genetic diseases
could be something that essentially
endangers the person at a certain time
or prevents them from developing certain
important functions as they grow and so
all of this
is linked to a variety of different
types of
genomic information that we could
acquire
and what's interesting is that as
opposed to just maybe a few years ago
this is now in the clinic so genomic
medicine
and the application of genomics in
treating patients
interacting with patients today is not
just something that we talk about
happening in the future
this is happening right now and it
starts from
collecting information that would help
us
interpret the found genomic mutations in
a patient sample
so that that could be incorporated into
the treatment plan
so today this is already being used
there are many different genetic
tests for history for different kind of
predisposition of risk
but also for treatment and for accurate
diagnostics
as i mentioned in cancer this is a very
critical component of
cancer care including the identification
of early stage signatures
that could help us treat cancer better
so as you know
cancer is a huge challenge around the
world
in many different parts of the world
there are different types of cancers
liver cancer breast cancer lung cancer
they
kill millions of people every year and
what is a
critical step in being able to address
cancer better
is early detection so the earlier we can
identify
a cancer developing in some cells the
earlier
they could be treated another important
part is
accurate and personalized treatment and
so that has to do with genomic
information as well as you all know a
good example of that
is the p53 gene this is a gene that is
typically found in many of the tumors
in many different types of cancers and
there
just a small number of mutations can
cause that gene to stop
functioning the protein that is encoding
will stop
functioning properly and essentially
will lead to unproliferated growth
and uncontrollable uncontrollable tumor
development so
this is an example in cancer
as you know as i mentioned there are
other types of
genomic information associated with
disease for example cystic
fibrosis and to really appreciate the
diversity of information that genomic
data provides
it really could be applied in so many
different cases
and there's a complex way to kind of
categorize these types of mutations to
really understand
what is their impact and so you can see
that
here we can see a number of different
types of mutations that are affecting
the protein synthesis the maturation and
processing
ion channel gating and others and so
when we look at the data that is
generated
about the genome we really need to know
how to analyze this data looking at
single point mutations and also
sometimes looking
at whole regions that are being changed
and so as a result when we speak about
genomic data and the variety of
different
use cases we can apply genomic
surveillance
genomic analysis for variant calling
as well as unsupervised analysis of
genomic data
ultimately to find associations between
the genomic variants and the phenotype
this phenotype could be disease as
it is caused by what's happening in the
human dna the host dna in the patients
or it could be caused by pathogens and
so
another whole important area of
application for genomic
data is the study of genomics
from pathogens from viruses bacteria
and from parasites and so tuberculosis
is one of those examples
as we know there is a huge problem with
drug resistant bacteria that is now not
responding to
a single type of antibiotic or
what's called a multi-drug resistant
bacteria as well
and those could be detected by analyzing
publicly available genomic data
so another example for this kind of
application is the ebola virus as we
know in the 2014
to 2016 the outbreak of ebola in west
africa
caused the whole world to be concerned
about ebola spreading around the world
and causing a pandemic
but thankfully because so much effort
has been put into
addressing this problem early on the
understanding of what causes
the mutations that are being acquired in
this new type of ebola strain were
identified
it was identified what is the critical
protein
and a vaccine could be designed very
quickly
and so that was a combination of factors
on one hand genomic data availability
and the efforts of researchers around
the world
on another hand it's the understanding
about the relationship between sequence
and structure which is a very important
part
of what we will be talking about in this
program
so one side it's the genomic data as you
can see
right here on the right on the other
side it's the proteins that are being
encoded by these specific genes
and how do these mutations actually fit
into that picture
and how we can utilize that so as i
mentioned
at the foundation here we have
the sequencing technologies that have
over the years
diversified providing us with a variety
of different types of sequence
information
and to understand how to process this
data
we have to understand how to analyze
this data properly
and so that's why in this program we'll
talk a little bit about
the history of genomic data sequencing
how to
analyze and identify specific mutations
how to categorize these mutations and so
there's a lot of
individual types of mutations that we
could think about
but we will try to go through all of the
different types
and terminology so that all of you are
prepared
to look at genomic data and actually
find associations with a phenotype
that you could link because you
understand the data
and so that brings me to this field of
bioinformatics
so ultimately what we talked about
up until now is the application of
genomics
in a variety of fields primarily in
biomedicine
but at the core of being able to perform
such projects and learn from this data
lies this bioinformatics discipline
and the bioinformatics discipline
combines the understanding of
biological challenges or biomedical
challenges that we just heard about
with two important aspects informatics
and statistics and so informatics has to
do with
information technologies and data
management how to find data
how to download data how to annotate
this data
how to store this data in in certain
formats
and then statistics how do we analyze
the
amount of data that we have to get some
meaningful information
out of it so that we can do inference so
that we can
infer from this data associations with
meaningful patterns that we know about
the patients that we are studying and so
the
intersection of these three fields
informatics statistics and biology
is actually the definition of
bioinformatics
and so to talk about bioinformatics and
to help people acquire
skills in bioinformatics i want to
introduce you today
to the omixlogic portal and some
important
things that you can gain from this
portal as we
speak about genomics in the virtual lab
the program that i will show you
in just a brief moment so
uh when we uh if you could please
uh go with me to omix logic the portal
so maybe somebody
can share the link
okay
so the link is learn.omixlogic.com
thank you sonalika please go to this
portal
and uh if you could please
register on this portal this is free
registration
and anyone who is participating in the
program or who would like to participate
in the program
would be leveraging some of the
resources we have on the portal
to be able to go through the session so
i will give you just a couple of minutes
if you could please register on this
portal the registration is free
and then we will speak about the topics
and the process for actual uh
registration to the program
okay so once you register please put
number one
or yes in the chat so i know that you're
already registered
okay thank you
i'll just give it a couple more minutes
so all of you that are registering as
you register
please let us know in the chat
and then i'll be able to show you a few
more things so that everyone
will be able to appreciate what kind of
resources are going to be available
for you in this program
all right great thank you i see a few of
you are registering right now
okay so once you have registered uh
you can go ahead and navigate to this
tab called
courses and i'll just give you a few
examples
of what has been uh made available
through this portal and how it fits in
with what we're going to be doing
okay so once you're on the courses tab
you can go ahead and navigate right here
if you're in the search tab to a
course called bytes and molecules now
this is a free course
anyone can take it and this will help
you establish some of the terminology
and the basic concepts behind genomic
data analysis
it will talk about why we should study
genomics
how we should study genomics and what
are some of the exciting examples of the
application of genomics in a variety of
fields
so you can learn about this by
completing this course
another course that i would recommend
for all of you that are joining today is
a course
called introduction to bioinformatics
so the first course will give you the
general background and the terminology
and will refresh your molecular biology
con
concept so that you understand how all
of this works together
introduction to bioinformatics we'll
introduce you to the challenges and
opportunities
with big data such as next generation
sequencing and how this data could be
analyzed
and it will go on into a more detailed
description
of the applications of bioinformatics
in the field of biomedical research
clinical applications
pharmaceutical drug discovery as well as
biotechnology and agriculture so i
highly recommend for all of you that are
interested to join the program to start
looking at this coursework it's very
accessible it's free and you can use
this right away
to prepare for the program that we're
going to be starting
now to talk about the program we can go
on the main menu right here to the
programs tab
and on here you will find a variety of
different
training programs that are not
asynchronous they're not online courses
they are guided by
a mentor and so this program called
uh genomics in the virtual lab is going
to be found right here
and in this program this is going to be
a special opportunity because it is
going to be guided by
someone who has years of experience
working in application of bioinformatics
to biomedicine
but also a program director that
is very passionate about education and
so instead of teaching
her master's degree program over the
summer
she is actually going to be spending her
time working with students
and beginners to give them the
opportunity to appreciate
bioinformatics and genomics in the
context of biomedical research
so i think this is a very exciting
opportunity
she has years of experience working for
nih
working at georgetown university medical
school where she is participating in
many different exciting research
projects
but also she is a director of a program
called
systems medicine and really a leader in
the field of systems medicine
where they speak about the need to
integrate
data including genomic data to be able
to offer better treatments
to patients with a variety of different
diseases so to understand what the
program is going to be like
i think we here uh have a video of a
group project that the previous
participants put together
uh you can scroll down and see some
information about
uh the schedule and the important thing
is that the
time for the program is going to start
from the
21st so on monday we will have our first
session
and it will go on for two weeks and
during those two weeks you'll be able to
learn
what you need to know to get started
with genomic data analysis
but uh in the later part of this session
we'll talk
about some of the other outcomes for
this program as well
so before um we continue we want to
mention
uh what the program is going to be like
and so i think we have
uh dr sona vasudevan from georgetown
university
who is going to speak a little bit about
the history
of bioinformatics and how it relates to
georgetown university
really the school that she represents so
you can hear a little bit about the
connection between bioinformatics
and genomics for
thank you okay go ahead
now there are lots of sub-disciplines
within bioinformatics
because bioinformatics is an
interdisciplinary field
because we need computer scientists we
need biologists
we need even economic economists right
now right
so we need it's an interdisciplinary
feat so there is a development of new
algorithms and you have statistics
because the minute you talk about big
data
you need statistics because you want to
see if this one single mutation
is actually statistically significant
for us to say yes
this particular mutation causes that
particular disease
right and then we have an analysis and
interpretation of various types of data
including nucleotides amino acid
sequences
protein domains and protein structures
and how do we get structures to function
and all of those things and then the
development and implementation of tools
because we can have we can generate data
we can have computer scientists to
develop tools
to look at the data and we also need
without tools we cannot even mine and
look at this data that's what this
course you're going to be learning about
a lot of resources where there is data
but also you're going to be using tools
to be able to
use how do you use the data without
tools right but
we are going to be focusing just on this
aspect of
nucleotides and acid structures and all
of that for the first one
right now is informatics a new field
what do you think i really love to ask
this question to
all my students and i get different
kinds of answers
so i would like to know of course i wish
i had some polling
uh set up so that we could have just
pulled now
what do you all think is bioinformatics
a new field
or not you can just type s or no answer
into the chat and we'll see
we'll just wait for a second and see
okay no bioinformatics is not a
oh is not a new field okay i'm seeing a
lot of new no
no no no no that is actually
no okay so bioinformatics is
actually you're right it's not a new
field right
so um where do you think it was born so
bioinformatics
is not a new field but where was
bioinformatics actually
born who gave to this whole field of
bioinformatics
any guesses of which continent when i
went to school it was seven continents i
don't know how many continents we have
today
uh but how did rosalind uh so you mean
grossly franklin
okay who who where was it born which
continent was it born you think
any guesses of where bioinformatics was
actually born
asia okay that would be my guess as well
um x-ray crystallography chromatography
of dna
usa okay probably in europe okay so
we're covering a lot of different
continents here we covered asia your
public europe
uh asia is coming up a lot europe is
coming up a lot
um uk yeah
sure okay so cuba okay good guess
actually i'm going to take someone who
just actually
uh maybe one who made the protein atlas
okay
we are actually coming really really
close that is very true
so bioinformatics has actually i spent a
lot of time on the slide just because
it's really fun to see
how people think right where it was born
um and um yes it was
actually i'm going to get closer to uh i
think it was parimalla
um or someone else said who uh usa
right so i think whoever said usa it is
actually correct so it was actually born
in the
u.s and uh it was actually i'm very
proud to say
that it it was actually born in the
universities i work in
georgetown university and i think
pariamala you are actually right
it was actually the person who actually
made the protein a class
and who is that person who made the
protein atlas
any guesses so
uh before i introduce um i have to give
tribute to this person
robert ledley he was a faculty at
georgetown he
actually died from alzheimer's disease
um
and he was the person who actually
discovered the whole body ct scanner as
well
and he actually published a paper in
1959
where he said he predicted
that 50 years or 30 40 years from when
he wrote that paper
that we are going to be drowned in data
and we are going to be dealing with
biological data
he is the person who actually hired the
person to georgetown
who actually gave birth to the entire
field of bioinformatics
and she is actually officially now
called
the father and the mother of
bioinformatics she was declared the
father and mother mother of
bioinformatics by
david lippmann who actually was the
director of uh ncbi
which we will talk about so yes those of
you who said it's a lady yes it is a
lady
and she was the one and she actually
came up with this atlas of protein
sequence and structures
it was actually before my time as well
in 1965
right so this is so in 1965 i don't even
know how many years ago that was
um where people used to actually get
sequences published in a book
people used to sequence and send the
sequence to margaret de hoff
and she used to just publish this in a
book
and this book was the one that was
actually uh posted to all the scientists
around the world
and that is how they used to get the
protein sequences right
so now what were her other seminal
contributions yes someone said i think
it was
parimla who said i put in atlas and
what and she gave birth at that point
she was a visionary she's considered a
missionary because people are
visionaries
they already think what's coming 50
years down the road she was the one who
said well we are going to have a data
explosion
so let's create what is called a
database so she was the person who first
created the protein database
and if any of you are visiting
washington dc sometime and you visit
georgetown i can take you to
actually the servers and all the books
that she published we still have it
because you know i used to hate history
uh in school but now i
love history and so i have actually kept
all her papers and everything else
as everything was coming along and she
also came up with the single letter code
for amino acids
i'm sure you all know what single letter
amino acid letter code is
right i'm sure i don't want to busy on
that but
is there any reason do you think that
she came up with the single letter amino
acid code for
example glycine gly is
gene right alanine ala is a
right so do you know why yeah efficiency
but other than the efficiency of course
it's very efficient right today we look
at it and it's extremely efficient
but think in 1960s why would she come up
with a single-letter amino acid little
code
what do you all think easier
representation yes that is definitely
true
but other than that you know you all are
in a generation where we have
gigabytes of data in your phone you're
pairing gigabytes of data in your cell
phone so you can do this whole thing in
a cell phone right
back then yeah it was lack of
computation power
back then they were talking about
kilobytes of data or even
megabytes of data so they did not have
in the super computers
so they wanted to make sure that they
don't have enough space so they have to
actually converted that to
single letter amino acid in fact i
learned all these stories from people
who work with her
who are actually still a church now
right coding storing information is
efficient that is correct so
now from that where did we head right
1950s
and of course you all know but watson
and creek right without watson and click
we won't be here today
and then we have sender sequencing
without sequencer we could not have
sequenced anything
right so insulin was the first protein
and then
of course things started evolving we
started seeing a lot a lot more
excuse me
we started seeing and then we started
seeing polymerase chain reaction
and then
and then we started seeing uh ncbi
and then we started seeing all of these
different databases
and it was in 1991
the official term bioinformatics was
coined and it came up in the literature
excuse me i think i'm screaming a lot
here
with out of excitement uh because of all
of you
right so then we started seeing all of
these tools that was developed
and all of those things and then we
started developing and a lot a lot of
different things started and you can
actually pay attention to here
where the whole genome project
initiative was actually started in the
80s excuse me
and then um and then the origin of
bioinformatics
the first protein sequence reported was
that of insulin
1956 it consisted of only one
51 amino acids and then
nearly a decade later the first nucleic
acid sequence was reported again there
is a faculty at georgetown who we
who actually passed away two years ago
jack shuriken he was the first person to
actually sequence a trna
when he was at princeton so
thank you so much oh just for uh sharing
the recording with us
so that was dr sona vasudevan
who told us about the brief history of
bioinformatics and discussed
what bioinformatics plays a role and
how it does so and she would be our
program mentor so before i pass it on to
uh dr mohit to discuss the session and
details
i would quickly want all of you to
please answer
few of my questions in the poll maybe i
can take the
poll after dr mohit as i
see some technical glitch over here
over to your doctor mohit thank you
hello everyone
just a second
and thank you dr sona for that wonderful
talk and before that elia
describing genomics and
what i wanted to discuss with all of you
can you see me now
yeah hello everyone it's it's great to
have you all here
and really happy to be in this
session so today as you have
already learned about genomics and
applications of application of genomics
and why bioinformatics and how
bioinformatics started
now i'd like to tell you more about the
program itself
so this is a great opportunity genomic
in the virtual lab
especially for those who are starting
with this field
who are new to this field and especially
designed for high school students and
beginners
so in this program we will have
different phases
and before i tell you more about the
program
uh let me tell you a little bit about
myself
so my name is mohit and i
am a biomedical data scientist so my
specializations are in
ngs data analysis and i am proficient in
applying machine learning
and has a detailed uh like you know
experience of working on structural
biology and
doing molecular dynamic simulations and
doing uh modeling
so uh in this program
i'll be one of the cool uh co-project
mentors
along with dr aubrey so one of my
research interests and
what what am i doing currently is
that uh about struck that is about the
structure function thing that
elia talked about so currently
uh we are working with a group uh in uh
in ghana and in in there we are working
with
uh infectious diseases such as
malaria and coughing 19 which is a very
big issue
especially malaria in in ghana so
uh in in the in the project i have been
uh
we have been able to look into the
mutations that could be you know
that could help design uh vaccine
strategies
so we are using genomics and for me i'm
using
i'm doing some of the structural
analysis helping
connect that how mutations actually
influence
the function of the structure so how
mutation
changes and why these mutations are
important and why some of the mutations
are not
not so important which are to focus
upon and how we can develop strategies
like
vaccine how we can develop strategies
like small molecules that can actually
go and block
uh these deadly disease to spread or to
you know
stop uh the severity of these diseases
so before that uh i been
working with several labs and working
with several students
so during my phd time i was i was able
to
um able to teach
a group of students who were doing her
their msc in bioinformatics
and then uh in uh since i joined fine
biotech i've been able to
communicate with so many of uh great
minds here
students from high school and scientists
and also people who are doing their
uh postdoctoral studies a phd uh
uh phd uh projects
so it has been really amazing to be able
to work on several
of these important aspects being a
person who has been able to understand
what data is
so to be able to work on sequence data
to be able to work on structural data
we have designed this amazing program
and now i would like to go
next to tell you that how this program
balances out both
sequence uh introduction to
bioinformatics and then
take you to the next level of
application of bioinformatics
so uh in this program we will have uh
different
uh stages so there will be week one
there will be week two and there will be
week three and week four so it's a one
month program as you can see
and uh during this uh entire
entire one month journey we will start
with very basics of introduction to
bioinformatics which is very important
and also india talked about the course
so uh please look at that so it will
start with
a detailed
video session by dr sona uh that would
be the first day
june um june uh
21st and then we will have different
aspects of
how bioinformatics is applied and we
will go into you know protein structures
we will go into three dimensional
structures from sequence
uh to understand how these you know
relationships
are there to understand and annotate
things
so in bioinformatics what happens is
that we do a lot of comparison
and we will use multiple sequence
alignment and phylogenetic analysis to
do
such comparisons and understand those
relationships
and then as i was telling you that the
exciting part of is to
able to come up with uh the holistic
understanding from sequence level to a
structural level to a to a functional
level
and then there will be a guest lecture
which i'm really really excited about
and then we have the second week where
we'll be discussing about uh detail
developing a project in the context of
application of genomics
so in this in this entire program we
will be using several
cloud-based tools and tools that you can
download and
apply in your own systems as well so
there will be a lot of computational
tools that you will be learning about a
lot
you'll be learning about a lot of
algorithms and how they work
and you will be also able to do hands-on
practice on all of them
we have also prepared data sets for you
to take
uh and also learn and apply this so you
we have already compiled genetic data
sets which have sickle cell anemia
cystic fibrosis and all of those
diseases or
also you can work on your own data set
so if you have
been thinking about a disease that you
want to work on if you
if you are have if you have that
interest we can obviously
look for data sets in this entire
program and then we will be able to work
on the project
so now i'll just quickly take you to
each of the sessions that will happen
during this entire course and also then
i'll take you to
i'll tell you that what you will learn
from this so the first session
will be about introduction to
bioinformatics as you can see on the
screen
and in this session uh we will be
working on
uh we will be learning about ole miss
technology and get an overview of
databases and resources
that is available to carry out
data-driven research
in sciences so in this session we will
learn about the introduction to
bioinformatics and different fields that
are
there and application in the second
session that i was telling you about
that we will be learning about genomic
variants so in this session we will
learn about dna nucleotides and amino
acid variants
as well as how this structural structure
and function
correlates so what happens in structure
how it affects its function
so think about it it like that if
something changes
uh so in the context of a protein
how this works is that from amino acids
or from nucleotides
uh we come to a level of amino acids
that is through
transcription and translation right and
then we have a protein which
is formed from 20 amino acids so you
have a lot of amino acids
in a chain that forms a protein and then
when you study here in the session you
will be able to what you will be able to
visualize this
that how in a three-dimensional space
the protein look how
how it looks what are the residues it is
you know build off
you can you will be able to look at the
chemistry so you'll be able to look at
the nucleotides that are there
you'll be able to look at the individual
uh charges that are there like if the
amino acid is built from carbon nitrogen
oxygen what are the bonding all of that
so
you will be able to visualize and learn
from the aspect of protein structure and
function
in the second session so after this
session the third session will be about
sequence alignment
so in this session we will learn about
multiple sequencing alignment of both
dna and protein sequences and this will
be again the hands-on session two will
be about
mutations and in 3d 3d structures
so as i was telling you that these
mutations like the variants you've been
learning about
uh the variants that have been like uh
annotated so often now and being
been annotated and and are
you know categorized as as variants of
concern
so why this is a way why there is uh the
variant of concern
because it concerns because it has such
a severity compared to
the uh the previous version of the virus
right
so a mutations i mean how much they
affect and it's fascinating
that uh simply like the virus mutates
and makes
it self such a devastating i mean
cause such a devastating uh effect so
i i am really excited to learn about
what
is the mechanism with which it does that
so how do you know about the mechanism i
mean you can know
you know about the mechanism when you
have the knowledge of how
the sequences what sequences it has what
what changes it has you know made to do
this
and then see that in the protein
structure i mean what is actually
happening
so why it is uh i mean what has changed
and
if uh if you can compare those two
structures
then you will gain a lot more insights
insights about uh
i mean maybe how it affects the function
and then
because of that it affects all of that
that happens
as a downstream effect right
and then we have the review session so
this is the last session of the week and
this will be
um through this these sessions will be
at 10 a.m um 10 am time
eastern time and for our
students and participants in india it
will be at
7 30 p.m indian standard time and for
people from other time zones
you could i mean please you can convert
this and
in this session it would be about the
guest
guest session and there will be an
interactive activities that dr sona has
planned for all of you
so uh in the guest session we have uh
dr felicia and i've been like really
really excited for this session i was
when i was uh when this was confirmed
that she'd be able to help you
and like uh give us all a wonderful
session
about her journey uh in uniprot so she's
one of those person and in this program
both
dr sona as india told and as you saw
that
dr sona was talking a lot more about uh
the history of bioinformatics
so dr celisia here is also one of those
people who have been
there from the very beginning as a bio
curator
biocurator and and managing
the enormous growth of data so it would
be really exciting to hear
about her journey so that would be the
session last session of that week
and after the session we have the we
have the weekend activity
as i also already told you that with
every session
we have a lot of online uh courses that
would be
made available to you so you can learn
at your own pace
and you can go through and learn about
some of the technologies and
try to apply that to real research
because that would be one of the
outcomes that we have seen in the
in the program so um
in in this uh in this activity
uh when you have learned about
visualization tools and such as pymol
uh then you will be able to apply this
into a disease or you know finding
a structure that that has that mutation
uh which makes it more you know
dangerous or which makes it
to identify those sort of projects and
then we will be using primo
so in this weekend you uh we will you
will have that
assignment to prepare a few slides about
uh
and find the structure and find uh and
use primal and all of that
so the second week is about research as
i was telling you it would be uh
it would be from our team uh
at omixlogic and in this session uh we
will
start in this week we will start from
literature review and project design
here we will learn about uh the review
of uh
what you have learned uh in the previous
session and we will learn about biology
and we will learn about how you can ask
about questions
like how big data research what what big
data research project is
what is the research question that
you're trying to ask and
how you can generate that research
question so as i was
discussing before that this this is to
design a research project
to be able to work on a research project
and to come up with you know
presentations and come up with
uh come up with uh posters
or maybe come up with a publication
uh when you have finished the analysis
which would be a very later phase of
of this entire journey so this session
will be dedicated to those
uh who who would want to work on project
and then we will learn about these uh
viral species
here we will learn about how genomics is
applied in virology
followed by this we will learn about how
you know how
metagenomics is a technique it's such a
powerful technique
that you should all uh should all be
aware of
you should all should learn about that
how uh
you know how to apply and understand
metagenomics
that can study i mean directly these
samples without culturing in the lab
very powerful technique and has been
widely used in many of these
natural and many of these
difficult times in this pandemic so
followed by this once we have the
understanding of
genomics and its application
metagenomics and
the application we will learn about the
vaccine antibiotic and antiviral drugs
and its strategy here we will learn
about um
about uh the basic principles behind
antiviral and antibacterial drug as i
was telling you that from
structure how you can understand and
design
uh these molecules design these bigger
molecules or smaller molecules
that could uh help us actually find uh
solution
right so uh followed by this uh
uh we will have the hands-on session in
the samsung session
we will go to ncbi and we will take
uh the entire genomes and do the
analysis through the t by info platform
and in this entire course you will be
also using the tbi for platform
which is a very powerful and
comprehensive tool cloud platform
which is an amazing place to
do your projects online so yeah so in
this session we will be using all of
that resources
and towards this end of the week we will
be helping you
and work on your projects and come up
with these project presentations
that could be reviewed by the judge in
our
symposium in august
so um to tell you more about uh the full
program registration
and how you can join the store maybe
right before you jump into that could we
launch the poll and just kind of uh
learn a little bit more about the
participants that's okay
okay so um uh
yeah you go ahead sonica
yes india so uh there is some uh problem
at my end
i'll get uh to you regarding this more
dr mohit can
uh take this no the poll is on uh
the poll is live yes people can see it
and their answer
so i'll just guide you everyone through
the questions that we have
the first question about your education
so high school undergraduate or
bachelor's
graduate or master's postgraduate or phd
or
post-doc student researcher or faculty
high school teacher or lecturer or other
so i see that the majority here are
undergraduate right now
we'll just give it a little more time
the second question is about your
research
interest so what are you most
interested in we chose topics that are
somewhat
general general and broad so
genomics bioinformatics data science
the future of medicine or introduction
to omics in general different types of
omics data
so if you could respond that question
number two
i see about 50 percent of you have voted
now so please
go on and the final one is where are you
from
so which country are you from united
states
india africa united kingdom
sri lanka bangladesh nepal russia
turkey or iraq so
this was based on some of the
submissions that we already had
and so that's why this was inserted so
abukari if you could answer in the poll
that would be helpful okay and i think
we'll leave the poll on for some time
and mohit maybe you could continue and
speak a little bit about the
registration
yeah thank you everyone for uh
answering the questions on the poll
and uh if you have any more questions
that are not there uh could you please
unmute yourself and ask me also i mean
if you want to ask
if you have any questions regarding the
program and the sessions and what we
would cover
uh please you can ask me also
by unmuting yourself about the full
program registration
so as you have already gone to the learn
platform
and have uh learn portal and have
created
a login i think next
next i will i will ask nalika to take
you to the
uh to the program page and show you the
registration details
so sunalika would you be able to do that
thank you so much thank you so much
so i hope you all have already signed up
on our uh portal if you have not then
you can do so
right away i'll wait for two minutes for
you all to please sign
up sharing the link with you all
so once you are signed up on the
comics logic portal
i'll just log in so that you can see how
you have to sign up
you need to add your email id create a
password for yourself
and sign in and you can also link your
social and sign up as well
so let me do through my social account
so that you get to know how it would be
done
you can now sign in yourself on the
portal
with me and please tell me if you have
done so
with a yes or one maybe on the chat box
so once you're signed in on the portal
you need to go to the programs and here
you will get the list of
all our programs which are ongoing and
the upcoming ones
as well so here you will get the program
genomics in the virtual lab
and as you can see here that you would
get all the information for the program
on the program page you would get to
know
about the program so this is one of the
project videos of our students from the
genomics in the virtual lab 2020 this uh
the program which was conducted last
year
and we had amazing outputs so i'll be
shortly taking you through the blog as
well and i'll tell you where you
can find more details about the projects
that were conducted by our previous year
students
and on the program page you'll have the
details of each and every session as
well the
dates would be marked on the calendar
here the
topics that would be covered in each and
every session
and this program page is also to be used
for your registration
so those who want to register themselves
for the
program they can simply go to the
program page
and register themselves as well now how
would they do so i'll just quickly take
you through it
this is the program page and you need to
start your application
i would be sharing the details with you
of how you would uh
take your application ahead the moment
we receive your registration with us
and i had few of the queries regarding
certification
so yes after the completion of the
program you would be getting the
certificate and this completion would be
awarded
once you finish all your assignments for
the program and the tasks given by you
by the mentor
and i just told you that we have all
these session
details as well on the program page and
each and every topic that would be
covered
so once we cover the session once the
session is over we would be uploading
the video of the session now this is
just an example program page
so we have the program ongoing machine
learning for biomedical drug discovery
we are done with the
three sessions we have the third one
today and the two of them the video has
been uploaded here
so we have in the webinar also the
people who have already enrolled
themselves for the program
so this is for your knowledge as well
that you will get the link to the
program page you need to bookmark it
uh and keep it with you throughout the
program and you would be able to
go to the program page and look for the
video if you missed out anything
and you you can refer to the video
anytime and do your assignments as well
and also you would have the zoom session
links for the upcoming uh
sessions and you can simply log in to
the session whenever the date of the
session is scheduled for
and now let me take you through
few of the more resources that you would
get the access to along with the program
so by being a part of the program first
of all you would also have the access to
all the courses
on our portal and also you would
definitely have the access to the t
by info server now this is a very
powerful
server now why do i call it powerful it
says that because we have
uh different sorts of utilities over
here
which have got integrated pre-built
libraries which could be used to carry
out different sorts of tasks and analyze
your data sets and we would get into
more detail of it in the program itself
and to get more details on the program
about what all would be covered who is
the speaker
and uh you can just go to our blog
page now this is the block
for the program
which has all the details of the program
and talking about nist chair nesha is a
collaborator
from sri lanka and
then we have the session details here as
well on the pro
blog which you could try for any time
and as dr mohit has already discussed
all these sessions
they are mentioned on the blog as well
i would also request you all to please
follow us on social so that you stay
updated with all
our upcoming programs and also
all the opportunities that we have and
also we keep on posting a lot many
opportunities
in the field of bioinformatics about
internships about recruitments and a lot
many more things as well
so being a part of this group on
linkedin would definitely help you so
i've shared the link with you
you can uh join the
join our group and also we are there on
facebook by the name buying biotech
and again i'm sharing a link with you
all join us there as well so that we
stay connected and you don't miss out on
any of the opportunity and the program
that we would be having
and before i finish sharing my screen
i would want to take the question
so
if i could interrupt you just for one
second yes
so let's go through the poll results
just to kind of share with all of you
what that
looks like it looks like we have the
majority or undergraduate students
and the second largest category is
graduate masters
so the reason i'm starting with this
question is because
we do have a number of additional
programs
that are targeted to the more advanced
students
including a research fellowship where
we're just
exclusively focused on helping you
complete your research using
bioinformatics tools
and there we have a number of mentors
that you can interact with
that are working using bioinformatics in
a variety of different research
fields so on the same program you will
find
the on this page you can see in the top
menu there's a
link to research so sunanika if you
could show the research page
so if you are a graduate student or an
undergraduate student
or a postgraduate student or even a
researcher that would like to
work on a research project we have this
three or six months research fellowship
program
you could check that out now let's go to
the next
what is your research interest uh so
a lot of you here are interested in
genomics and as we already mentioned
genomics has
many different applications and
sonolique if you could now go to the
home
page on the home page we have
the four categories of
different types of projects that we have
uh yes the home page
okay so if you scroll down we have here
there we go oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture so
what you will find on this portal are
not just
lessons and tutorials but also project
examples the project examples are
sourced from
the public domain so they're from uh
journals
uh please go back so then i could just
stay on the four
sections please so um in each one of
these categories we have
project examples from peer-reviewed
journals
we take the data follow the same
analysis approaches that are described
provide some insight into alternative
methods of analysis
and uh also open it up
for your independent project on the same
topic
and so now sononeke if you could go down
below and show
how some of the research fellows that
we've had in the past
have been able to use this training to
design
a project of their own so we have a
whole page dedicated to this
and you can see here a few of the
examples so if you would like to work on
an
independent research project the
genomics in the virtual lab program is a
great place to start
and as you get started you will see how
we have a whole
structure for you to follow from a basic
research question
to identifying the data set to then
being able to work on an independent
project
okay and then finally we did ask about
what country you're from so we have here
india is the largest the second one was
from
africa and then the third one is from
the united states
so from india i did want to
mention that we have a number of campus
ambassadors
that you can connect with if you have
an interest in finding out a little bit
more about how this works
learning about the research fellowship
program if you have any questions so we
have a whole set of
undergraduate and graduate students in
our research fellowship
and so we invite you to connect with
them and the way to connect with them
and maybe even hear from their
experience is to email
sonalika or join our
social media group on linkedin and on
facebook
and letting us know that you would like
to talk to someone
so we will be sharing with you some
details
and yes you can email marketing at
pine.bio if you have any other questions
thank you okay and uh so
we um will i saw that there's a question
sonic and maybe you can just show
if you log out from your learn account
and show the program page without being
logged in
and just walk us through the
registration
pricing and what are the different
options
thank you
and by the time my page is loading i
just wanted to tell that we are also
there on telegram
and whatsapp so we have groups for
telegram and whatsapp as well so that we
have
direct communication with you all and i
would be sharing the links of our groups
as well and you you can be a part
of our groups and uh ask us anything
anytime and we would be there to help
you out with that
so for the registration process here on
the program page itself you go to the
same link
and then you need to start your
application
here is the link you need to start your
application and you would be directed
towards the different sorts of level we
have for this program
so we have the bigness level the
intermediate and the advanced level
and uh the difference is because of the
different
sorts of provisions that would be given
throughout the program
so the bigner one has got the provisions
mentioned and intermediate one has got
one on
one mental support as an additional
benefit
as uh being part of the intermediate
level for the program
and the advanced level would have some
more options as in to get extra time to
work on a project and then the option is
there for certificate for completion
that that is
though for every uh level that you would
be in
but there isn't also an option for
certificate of excellence as you would
be getting some more time to work on
a project of your own right and
uh to talk about the further details so
let's say
any one of you chooses the intermediate
level let's say you just need to
sign in and then check out so the moment
you check
out you would be directed towards the
payment page
and once you're directed towards the
payment page you need to add the coupon
code that i shared with all of you over
the mail ids
and sorry and if you didn't get one then
you can let me know and i will share
with you once again
sorry my system has got yes it's working
now
yeah so that's it i hope your uh doubt
is cleared anik so anybody else if you
have any doubt you can ask
i am till then sharing the links of our
sokiyas the price is not affordable for
us
africans in eucupia so
uh kia we would be sending can you
please drop me a mail at
marketing at the refine dot bio so that
we can discuss
about the different sorts of
opportunities
anushka says can you please share the
code yes uh sure
anushka can you please do the same as i
asked kiara to do so
please mail me and i would be able to
revert you back
just within a few minutes and i'm
sharing the link of a telegram group
so be a part of our group we have a
channel and also group by a name of
sciomex
that's a bioinformatics community where
we have
students by informatics background
and different fields as well and there
we have
free live sessions every week and we
discuss
different sorts of
topics like we had uh one
session yesterday where we discussed
about
astrobiology and our research fellows
were there subrajeet and
dila dekken who shared about
astrobiology
and how it could change the whole way
the
the way we look at science and it was
really interesting
so if you guys are not following us on
youtube you can do that right away i'll
share the link
of a youtube channel as well because we
keep on uploading videos for each of our
session there and also we are live right
now by the way
and being a part of a youtube community
you would definitely be
able to uh look at all the webinars and
sessions if you miss
out any one of them uh then and uh yes
you could be benefited in that way so
this is our youtube channel
it's link
uh okay dr pankaj asks the
feedback link for participation
certificate sorry dr pankaj
feedback link as in a feedback link for
the program
for the certification feedback link i
didn't get sorry
uh could you please specify what you are
saying
a bukhari has a question he says working
with
yes sir you can let me answer that one
please yes so abukari
um we have um some tools that you can
use with
amplicon sequencing for uh plasmodium
falciparum
and uh maybe what i would suggest
uh depending on your level of
bioinformatics your
you know previous bioinformatics let me
ask you maybe a few questions so that we
can understand
do you already have experience using
bioinformatics tools for genomic data
analysis
at bukhari
you can also unmute yourself i think
let me actually find you so i can help
that
um so uh
the tools that we have
okay yes and and i think somalico for
you it's saying that the whatsapp group
is already full so you can't join that
okay so um i've asked to unmute you if
you can
okay can you hear me yes we can hear you
good so i started with
kind bio infectious disease
and we just completed the core psd
i also did that with transcriptomics i'm
generally with
a few courses to finish and this is how
far i have started with
find value i hope to register this
particular course and
my interest in time i will
basically stand with the fact that i
wanted to help me impact positively
in my upcoming project that we're going
to do
sample consequences with people's
family okay
so because you've already done a lot of
the training
and you probably have a theoretical
understanding of what are the steps that
you need to do
to get you to now apply these skills
that you've acquired to a
practical project i would recommend
joining the research fellowship so the
research fellowship program
is intended to help people like yourself
that have completed the training
go through identifying the type of data
which you have the amplicon sequencing
the application would be to plasmodium
and then potentially thinking about what
kinds of
questions would you like to study would
you like to address with your project
potentially you're looking for
vaccine efficacy or maybe you're looking
for
drug resistance or maybe you have some
other questions maybe genetic
variation in nigeria let's say or
something like that
and so a lot of these topics are best
when you do literature review you can
refine your question
understand where you should focus your
efforts then
once you've got the data you would do
the exploratory data analysis and
understand the variation
and then ultimately once you are done
preparing that project and sharing it
with the rest of the research fellows so
we actually have a whole group focused
on
plasmodium we have a group in ghana
out of the naguchi memorial institute
for
biomedical research and also we have a
group in africa and nigeria
where they have a few people joined in
the research fellowship
and they have this uh common interest in
malaria so
maybe that would be the best next step
for uh
your situation avocado
i'm very grateful thank you
all right yes thank you for the question
as well
so um if anyone else has any question
uh please go ahead i think i've made it
possible for anyone to unmute themselves
so if you have a question
please do let us know you can also
unmute yourself and speak
and i think the question about the
feedback link
and the certification so we don't
provide
a webinar certification these are really
webinars to facilitate discussion
and introduce some of the upcoming
opportunities
we have quite a number of free webinars
that you can join throughout the month
some of them are related to our research
fellows presenting their research
projects
some of them are to discuss important
topics like the psionics club
some of them are to introduce some of
the upcoming training opportunities so
please
take a look at either the social media
groups
or the youtube channel where we share
some of those uh sessions with everyone
but because we're sharing it publicly we
don't really
provide a certificate with those
so um and that's just to answer that
question
okay gerald is asking what are the
bioinformatics tools that the program
requires the learners to use
uh so dr vasudevan comes from a
structural biology background so she
will be talking about tools like pymol
but she also has a lot of experience
with genomics so probably sequence
alignment so clustal
blast and things like that as sonalika
already mentioned
you will have access to the t by info
platform
so let me just briefly share with you
some of the tools that are available
all of you that have registered on the
learn portal
will have access to a demo pipeline
already for free
so you can go ahead and explore this
platform and see what kind of tools are
available here so
thank you selenico for sharing that link
so as you can tell there are many
different tools available and they're
organized in such a way that you can
build fairly complex pipelines without
minimal background in bioinformatics
there are some examples you can take a
look here at some of the examples in
transcriptomics
or here you can see some examples for
other tools like
phylogenetic tree of different types of
methods that we have included so really
this is
many different tools for multiple
sequence alignment for mapping of the
raw reads to the reference genome of
building phylogenetic trees
there are tools for processing data and
analyzing it with different types of
unsupervised and supervised methods of
analysis
so those are the tools that are going to
be covered in the program
but what you should probably know coming
into the program
are some of the basics about sequences
what they look like as well as what
kinds of questions could you ask now let
me share
just one more thing
on the learn portal let me just go to
the home page again
under coursework a lot of the tools that
you've seen
on the tauber portal are actually
scripts
in r and python and so one of the things
that you will be able to do
is take some of these and learn about
how they are
implemented so if you go to the courses
you can take a look at introduction to
genomics which is a good place to start
but also
you can see getting started with
bioinformatics in python and getting
started with bioinformatics and
r so here you will find some scripts
that you can run directly in the browser
and understand
how to analyze sequences and visualize
data
okay so what is the role of
bioinformatics in discovery of new
coveted vaccines
um well so it's obvious that vaccines
are going to have to continue and
improve
as we see new variants of concern and as
we see
other viruses coming out and becoming
potentially pandemic so i think there's
definitely a huge need for new vaccines
and vaccine
improvements now as we think about the
vaccine
function and how they are designed you
will
understand the relationship between
sequence and
structure and then immune response and
in that process bioinformatics plays a
huge role because we need to understand
what variants to focus on
what impact do those variants have on
immunogenicity
how do they interact with the different
receptors and so
that's where the vaccine design field i
think is going to go because
the process of going from a known
sequence and structure
to being able to produce those proteins
or rna really is i think something that
was proven to be very effective in this
pandemic
gerald is asking is the program geared
towards structural biology and
biophysical methods in the context of
bioinformatics no it's going to combine
genomics with structural biology so how
do you do sequence alignment
how do you understand the relationship
between sequence and phenotype
and then how can you map this on the
structure
to understand the relationship between
the two
okay
okay thank you so um i don't see any
more questions so hopefully we were able
to answer all of those
thank you so much and the last thing i
wanted to share with all of you is that
we also have a lot of programs which
would be
starting by the end of june and also
the first week and middle of july so
though
so we had a question regarding sas
growth too
so we have this uh program coming up
which would start from 9th of july
and you can just go to the program page
and get the details of it and if this
interests you
maybe you can be a part of it and learn
more about how we can
uh use bio and by informatics
effectively
to do research in this particular domain
and then we have bioinformatics for
infectious diseases program as well
that would be starting on uh on
22nd of uh june and
last but not the least we have the
genomics in the virtual lab
about which we are here to discuss about
and the program would be starting on
june 21st
and the last day to register for the
program is
june 20th we would be closing the
registrations
at the end of june 20th so you all are
requested to register
if so for the program and yes that's
it so thank you everyone for joining
today's webinar
and if you have any doubts and if any of
your questions went unanswered or you
could not
ask me you can anytime nailers at
marketing either a fine dot bio
and move it either a fine dot bio and me
and dr mohit would be there to
help you out at any step
india dr pankaj has a question regarding
clinical trials or vaccine whether it is
helpful
can you please take that
i i would just maybe suggest we ask a
few questions so
dr pankaj kumar um maybe we could
schedule even a conversation it sounds
like maybe you're involved in related
research so we'd love to learn a little
bit more about it
you're welcome to email me elia pine.bio
and i'd love to set up a chat to learn
more about your interest
thank you elia and dr deepak we would
definitely look forward to have a
conversation with you
and gerald uh you can't login into tao
service like that
so you need to first sign up in the
omics logic
and then you need to be a part of our
program
uh any of the programs that we have it
could be the but the program for which
we are here today
or the research fellowship program or
the programs that would be coming up and
then you would get the access to the t
buyer info server
we would be giving you the access for
that and if
you want the access to the server to
carry out your research work only and
then you can reach out to me for that
i'll send you all the details how you
could get that
and then you can maybe use the server
with the credentials
and do your research i hope that answers
your question
animaka says you want to develop your
project on neuroscience what options i
have so i
animaka we are already working on a lot
of new neuroscience projects in our
research leadership program
i uh received your message over linkedin
as well i'll send you the details
of the program and i'll also send you
the
project examples for new neuroscience
you can go through them and get an idea
of how the research fellows
our ex research fellows worked on it and
then we can proceed further yes
thank you so much everyone for uh being
here for the webinar
it was really really great to know you
all and we look forward to your
participation in the program
and also meeting you on uh different
sorts of other webinars
and stay connected with us over social
so that we
keep our meeting again and you don't
miss any of the
update on the upcoming programs uh
solandia i have one question
yes please right yes
yeah well i try to click on the you know
you show the four different real project
on home page
yeah when i try to click the lawnmower i
could not do that
do i need to do anything or
if you're not able to do that then let
me share with you the block of the
research fellowship program
and you can maybe i could just one
second clarify yeah so that is the
blog post that you should take a look at
but if you go into the courses tab
uh you'll see that you can search there
um what is available so um
let me just show right here
so if you go to the courses tab
yes right here you can search for a
specific project if it's available
and so we have a few examples or if you
would like to develop an independent
project in one of these areas
again take a look at some of the
examples that sonalika shared in the
blog
those are examples of projects that
students have completed
in the research fellowship so if you
would like to develop something like
that you can go to
research and that tells you a lot of the
information that you need to know
of how this works and some of the
examples down here as well
yes i'd like to um develop independent
project yeah
um so
for that for an independent project
maybe we could also schedule a time to
speak
uh learn a little bit more about your
background your interest
what exactly you're interested in um so
if you could email sonolique and myself
and we could schedule a time to meet
with you okay
okay that will be great
all right thank you so much
i hope that helps you and thank you so
much everyone for being a part of the
webinar
uh let's meet the next time thank you so
much bye bye take care
okay bye